So how do you use means ends analysis to solve Raven's Progressive Matrices?
What exactly is our goal in this context?
You might think of the goal in different ways. We might think of it as,
the goal is to solve the problem or in a different sense we might think of
the goal as the transform sum frame into another frame. And then trace back and
find what the transformation was? In that context how would you then measure
distance? We noticed that distance is important in doing means ends analysis
because that helps us decide what to do next. Once you have a measure of how to
actually measure distance to your goal what are the individual operators or
moves that you can take to actually move closer to your goal and
how would you weight them to be able to decide what to do at any given time.
In addition, what are the overall strengths of using means and
analysis as a problem solving approach in this context,
and what are its limitations. Is it well suited for these problems, or are there
perhaps other things that we can be doing that aren't necessarily under this
topic that would actually make the problem even easier.